this man has hundreds of credits on his
filmography and TV ography Breaking Bad
sons of anarchy heat dusk till dawn
anaconda machete machete kills grind
house he's perfect host for the second
season as he was the first of El Rey
network's man-at-arms Art of War
thrilled to have here Danny Trejo once
again thank you so much good to see you
for many reasons number one as you know
we've had you on before and I had a
great time I'm a fan as well also there
was an Internet hoax about your
well-being
somebody don't like me that everyone's
going on what's going on with that Danny
Trejo is not dead was the five weren't
weaned from from your account two years
ago and it happened again just recently
right yeah yes it's going on man don't
like me trying to offer you I'm glad
that wouldn't be so hard dad there's
only five places you go during the day
Chubby's automotive or the pantry or or
your your date Rao's tacos coffee and
doughnuts or set somewhere for for what
you're doing so you must be far I mean
there is a this is a great time to be a
Los Angeles sports fan that you are die
hard for correct you were at the Rams
Vikings game yeah yes yes they didn't
beat the spread but they want everybody
the Greek trail right there and the Rams
are undefeated this is as good as they
or no as any team has been in the NFL
and I just I used to sneak into the
Coliseum when the Rams were 1957 and
5856 we used to sneak in there before
you could just go into the bathroom and
then go in with a family you know no wow
it's like to see them now it's like
unreal yeah I never stopped being a fan
of the Rams but when they left I just
started you know what's your team what's
the spread right and really matter right
so and we're seeing right now you
hanging out with Eric Dickerson yeah you
are right there and you know my best
friend Baby Bash who I started a wreck
company with right trejo music he played
with Eric Dickerson on uh on a celebrity
football game and scored he scored four
touchdowns Eric Dickerson said be a hell
of a running back yeah yeah there you
are with soo I mean that guy's huge - OH
what is the role that you people
recognize you for the most that you're
stopped on the street and say hey you're
that guy from really honestly I hate to
say it no I don't but Spy Kids I did a
movie called Spy Kids Robert Rodriguez I
did four movies and people I had
five-year-old kids come on I mr.
Marchetta I love you as my kid and I
just that was 15 years ago this kid
would he would but kids about 18 19 20
years old to be the best babysitter's
we've ever had
just put in the CD so it's funny so then
one day when these spy kids grow up and
getting to see you in the Robert
Rodriguez mousse or Tortuga on breaking
eight-year-old kosair I love you much do
you really get that yeah wait a minute
so eight-year-old you're watching come
on mom I know that in watch with this go
over to somebody's house yeah you don't
get a lot of Konnor you get a lot of
calm
every time I get into a plane captain
will come out hey all right I just got
back from Texas yesterday yeah and the
pilots on the plane were like hey what's
up we got to put you in gun I'll be all
right yeah I love it
and then what about heat you got a good
story from the city heat I mean with
Pacino De Niro right what was that like
that was like you know that's like
sitting at the World Series with the
star pitcher I mean he's like those are
- those are the Val Kilmer I'll be your
huckleberry
he should have won an Oscar for that
movie I don't care what anybody says but
for two stone Al Pacino
robert de niro that said that says
that's a hand right jon voight yeah
that's the hand did you give him any
tips on being an ex-con
I love being an ex-con on the city had
we had some what do you call it we had
some where you sit around and talk about
it oh yeah and it was pretty cool there
there they were pretty sharp yeah they
did their homework
you know they actually did their
homework and in my wildest I would never
you would think that they had been in
prison all of them you know they did
they did really unbelievable and then uh
their neuroses Scotties is so fun to
watch man he's just so fun to watch it's
like he's like walking through this
dream watching me like watching a dream
he's just like amazing to watch and then
val kilmer the same thing you know Wow
sure what's the most nervous you've ever
been on a movie set that's it right
there when I met him you know what I
gotta tell them when I was doing my jet
they and Robert De Niro came to do much
hit there with me right he played the
the senator that was it was gonna build
a wall okay really this is Robert
Rodriguez is amazing because he
predicted all this stuff ten years ago
and uh and when Robert DeNiro saw me he
goes hey you huh you yeah you number one
on the call sheet and I was stunned by
this terrible mmm all I could say was
can I get you some coffee mr. DeNiro
did you get him did you got him donut
donut shop here in Los Angeles Danny
Trejo here on the Rich Eisen show so
you're perfect for for this TV show that
you made together
what man-at-arms Art of War where you're
you're using all different sorts of
weaponry well we build them but we just
build them show you how to build this we
go into the history of them you know the
history how they how they won Wars you
and how they were used this dubbing and
the demonstrations demonstrations are
awesome and there's one episode word you
know it's like you got to be really
careful cuz there's some really really
dangerous weapons what's the easiest job
you've ever had Essen acting is it right
here this show no this is this is this
one is like oh I think it's most
dangerous the most dangerous job I mean
like you can seriously get hurt yeah I
mean you know it's think you got
something that's so sharp you can cut a
camel oh I I uh I cut a watermelon
mm-hmm right in half and it stayed right
there didn't even fall and at first I
thought I missed it
mm-hmm and then you just pushed in it
was just went right through it okay so
you can actually you need to get some
troubleshooting the troubleshooter
studios now you've got a team I guess
kind of make the turn here a weapon like
LeBron James here in Los Angeles that I
mean you must go back to the Lakers way
back well you're talking if you're
talking about sneaking into the Coliseum
when you did you're talking about when
they arrived here from Minneapolis he's
quite a skip I I'm just so amazed that
he's here and if you ever seen him in
person he's like this man yeah no we saw
him we were at media day last week and
he comes walking out from behind a
curtain and I it had been a few years
since I'd seen him cuz I haven't been in
an NBA Finals in a while and he he's a
massive human being and I couldn't he's
so funny I tell you you know I I was in
Florida mm-hm and I don't know if the
lady was right or not but I was that was
what I smoked right I was smoking
sitting and uh the lady comes down says
can I have a cigarette
sure gave her cigarette mm-hmm we're
smoking I don't my son see she's smoking
a cigarette
LeBron J got to see her back
so LeBrons sneaking a smoke I'm gonna
cigarette off the Danny Trejo is a
really I guess little abroad had wanted
her to stop smoking now that right there
is a story that you don't expect so this
is when you were smoking and he was in
Miami
yeah and now here you are yours later
yeah now maybe you go to Staples
absolutely you don't smoke anymore no
okay maybe mrs. James doesn't anymore
either but he is when he got a car whoa
this guy's so you did see him then yeah
I saw him there okay
now he's a Laker it's amazing it really
is Danny Almonte world but it's like you
know what but goes around comes around
you know I uh I love where I'm at right
now
Iran via Baby Bash we're after the game
that's where it's the bottom of the
steps and Baby Bash is a hell of an
athlete right I'm he's I watched him
shoot a basketball from one basket woe
to another and make it for ten grand for
charity and made it right right and and
we're at the bottom of steps and I said
go for it and then we ran those steps
you know I'm 74 yeah I know he's nowhere
near and he made yeah we both made it up
to the top and then he said okay I go no
and the internet still can't kill you
off easy
hey it's good to see you here Danny
man-at-arms Art of War
on the El Rey Network premiering this
Thursday at 8:00 Eastern Time ten
episode season come back any time lately
awesome thanks for being here god bless
you got a Danny Trejo here on the Rich
Eisen show go Rams the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience